will and how might nature respond to our
potential lab leak
i want i guess i don't know what is
meant by nature here you know if we're
talking about sort of wild nature or um
or you know
we are we are all part of nature so well
do you want to take a crack at what
might be meant here there's a lot of
things that could mean we made an
argument early on
i i still think it's important actually
it's a counter argument to one of the
things that sam has recently said
he said he was quiet about the lab leak
because what difference would it make
and we've we've argued often why it
would make a difference right one reason
is because if you've effectively used
uh gain a function if you've used serial
passaging for example to draw a virus in
a direction that it had not already
evolved you've effectively put tension
on a rubber band and you should expect
that when it encounters
the world of phenomena that it will be
pulled in the other direction so you
could predict where it was going to go
now
that said
so for example
were it the case that a serial passage
experiment had resulted in it
surrendering the capacity to transmit
outside because the serial passaging
experiment took place inside
and it got some characteristic for
foregoing that tension then you would
expect it to return to the ability to
transmit outside right that's one
example of a way in which an experiment
could have pulled it one way and then we
would expect it to naturally fall back
the other way just the same way that if
you i can see the opposite argument
though
i mean in in this case i guess i i had
not before heard you describe this as
like a rubber band the selective force
uh the selective force could also be
accelerating in some direction such that
the the virus now has a tendency to seek
out more change in the same direction
well you could do that too you could be
you could effectively solve a problem
that the virus can't solve in nature and
in fact we did that if this is a level
sure
that feels like the more obvious way
that we exerted selective pressure if we
use gain of function to create this
virus yeah but if you think about it
like
um the
the argument i made in my dissertation
about the tension between dispersal and
competitive
uh strength
and that effectively
in a maple tree no no in things
generally so if you look at hawaii
that's what i'm saying like
in in anything not specifically viruses
not to humans to anything
what should you expect to be to to
characterize the creatures of hawaii
they're all going to be excellent
dispersers at least the native ones
right what does that mean about their
competitive strength they'll be feeble
because the point is there's a trade-off
between those four reasons i make an
argument for but never mind so the point
is you would expect it getting to places
and having gotten there everything else
is just as good at getting places and uh
has not been able to put resources to
competition competitive strength right
yeah so they will they will have
borrowed
to get dispersal they will have borrowed
from competitive strength and they will
have reduced selection for competitive
strength in a low diversity environment
which is a natural consequence of it
being a remote island
that said if you solve a dispersal
problem if you take a mongoose to hawaii
it's going to have a field day because
it's a very strong competitor right and
lots of things so hawaii is very
vulnerable unlike a mainland tropical
habitat hawaii is very vulnerable to
invasion because it has all these feeble
competitors why are they feeble because
they're excellent dispersers if you
overcome the dispersal uh barrier
barrier then
then of course they're gonna win right
so
the implication is that
we effectively solved if this was a gain
of function
uh escape e we effectively solved a
dispersal problem for the virus so it
didn't have to solve it we gave it the
keys to the human kingdom and then
having gotten in there you would expect
it to find its own equilibrium or you
know potentially the keys to like the
ace ii kingdom right right yeah that
said
we are
okay so we solved the dispersal problem
you would expect it to naturalize into
the human population and then we have
interfered with a novel kind of vaccine
that is almost cartoonishly narrow in
its evolutionary scope and therefore we
are now pushing the virus around we have
used the vaccine to interfere with
now we have interfered with the vaccine
right no we have interfered with the
evolution of the virus after solving a
dispersal problem assuming this was a
lab leak which is an assumption but a
more and more likely one
then we are now pushing it around
evolutionary we're pushing the virus
around evolutionarily so it won't find
an equilibrium it will move in response
to our evolutionary pressure that we are
exerting yep um speaking of which
there's another question here trusting
if sars kovi 2 makes the evolutionary
leap to transmit outdoors you will tell
us
um yes and and what we've said is
although we're not you know especially
in our main podcast we're spending a lot
more time talking about the you know the
broader ideas of the book rather than um
this particular moment in time that we
find ourselves in with regard to covet
stuff um we have said that we you know
if if
things arise uh that run counter to what
we have said publicly we will absolutely
come come back with that and
um
i still have not seen so you have said
that there are a couple of super
spreader events that seem to have been
at outdoor events but it is of course
possible um that the way that they were
effectively super spreader events was in
like bathrooms right uh and so so and
that is the only and i don't actually
even know all i know
my entire knowledge of this is from you
i have seen nothing and it's not for
lack of you know swimming in this
literature a fair bit um to suggest
um that there has been uh anything like
a change in terms of transmissibility
even in the delta variant well
regard to outdoors versus indoors yeah
yeah so i believe we are beginning to
see that i don't think it's a strong
pattern yet but it's uh i what i've seen
is not easily dismissed as it was a
bathroom or something like that that
remains a possibility but in one of
these cases it doesn't look likely but i
would also point out it could be
a natural consequence of the increased
transmissibility
right the idea is if you take the model
that we were developing
a year ago
[Music]
right where basically you've got a
space it has a volume it saturates at
some rate
you are not likely to be infected if
you're healthy and you're in the space
for a short period of time
um but if it's saturated you'll get it
and then there's something we need 100
units with the original variant and now
you need 50. right yeah so the point is
can you conceive of an outdoor space
that saturates like an indoor space
maybe not with the original variant and
maybe you can with something that's much
more transmissible yep so um you know
something like that that's how my model
is that makes sense to change no that
makes that that makes some sense yep
[Music]
you